morning good morning welcome to the
castle
Gordon and your first name sorry my name
is Brittany I'm the manager I have you
in room 117
that is $105 during the weekday and 135
dollars on the weekend okay I think
Gordon's first time president of the
hotel is going to be what the [ __ ] are
these people doing the Kami to tell
r.i.p yes sir see yes
it's died you mean no rest in peace is
the ghost that huh live here we are
haunted oh come on there's a little girl
who supposedly haunts the hotel Alice -
oh my good god
she looks like something out of the
Exorcist she was four years old in 1913
when she died but I believe in ghosts at
the hotel I absolutely believe in them
can I go up the stairs and oh god I let
the owners know this place is littered
with freaky pictures I'm taking Ken to a
local bar I think that meeting the right
girl will give them a great confidence
boost the sort of positive energy that
will light up the river rock and make
pleasure to deal with invited dinner
tomorrow I rock in yes tomorrow night
yeah we like it tomorrow yeah so we have
an old toast to Kenny finding a
girlfriend over to Kenny come on it was
really great Eagle boost I felt like the
king boy he really set me up
thank you very much if I fail now I'm
really a loser
big date tomorrow good night
honestly I've never seen a man change so
much let's just hope he's not late for
breakfast in the morning its rack of
lamb and crusted in macadamia nuts fresh
herbs and a little bit of Dijon mustard
it's served with a honey vinegar
reduction it's not even cooked properly
I was getting nervous when you see white
fat like that on the side of the chop is
it to your liking I mean it's pretty raw
in the center you like the flavor of it
though the honey Carrie no way too sweet
I'm not satisfied with the quality the
food's coming out of the kitchen
I believe our chef has a learning curve
to be where he needs to be thank you
we just lost our other chef why did the
chef leave that's what's to tell you the
truth right the truth is all I want to
know why did the chef leave well her
paycheck she put all her everything on
her charge cards and and she just
beckoned she wasn't paid back for what
she's chef bought produce she did she
did everything she was the best chef
ever probably as dreadful and starving
the peanut butter chocolate decadence I
could do with some that pick me up
please thank you God I said that left
because you have to buy produce on her
own credit card I mean this guy's
priorities are upside-down been like
this in this he said he doesn't care for
the sweetness this fat around it he
didn't care for the flavor of the honey
Garr
[Music]
Wow
thank you very much did you cut in half
because it looks like so and where's the
other half come oh it goes to the
another person who watered oh no I won't
mind a half $74 this place is insane
listen half my desserts missing
if you think I'm spending $74 for
dessert that is half-cocked
[Music]
hmm it's actually quite nice there is
hope I'm sorry you know I'm going to say
that that is not a dessert that he made
baba made it no somebody else makes
desserts it's ordered like store-bought
like through one of our purveyors what
thank you very much chef orders up great
thank you
get them going brother get them going I
think that Gordon is gonna love the food
chef rich is great we put out excellent
food you chef
Wow look at that this is the pork and
beans
holy mackerel it is calling mini-me both
you yeah just touch the meat there
please I can see why we got our IPA on
the front of the [ __ ] reception those
are two medium-rare is right scooter
chuck them in the oven please chef ice
cold in the middle Tom it's a sous-vide
product we cook it to order it
disappoints me a little bit that we are
boiling bags putting stuff in the
microwave I wish we could actually cook
with fresher food duck confit and chef
said the pork and beans was a sous-vide
product and it's cooked to order
sous-vide I took it back yes they're
frozen frozen yes and this plate that's
frozen I think that's a sous-vide
product as well do we have anything that
is homemade are the apple pies made here
the apple pies are made here okay can
you hurry the desserts please sure thank
you so far everything has been terrible
surely the hotel's signature dish is
gonna be better how's that fine
to complain anymore I'm sorry
but this is the home of my love most but
if it's all about landlord it should be
really been asked
[Music]
Alamogordo so this is it this is the
that is the paella mode [ __ ] this plate
is absolutely roasting the center has it
been microwaved it has the apples are
raw if there's one thing I was expecting
was a decent apple pie and that is gross
yeah here is the chocolate Pig it's
white and dark chocolate strawberries
bacon it's like we've had a crises with
the toilet paper department someone's
wipe their ass with my daughter I mean
it's just I've never seen anything so
[ __ ] unappetizing as a dessert and all
my life absolutely bacon and chocolate
pizza OMFG yes you didn't like any of it
no one thinks [ __ ] me
why do I have to ask weekly for fish to
be eyes down do not take this sign down
do not take my pens by your own if you
use this through replace it or buy a new
one with your paycheck bloody hell
Charmin can definitely have issues let's
see how if you eat these cookies take
one to your next job interview I mean my
god I'm surprised anyone still [ __ ]
works here this guy is incredible this
is insane
I can't believe Ken is so
passive-aggressive with his staff koala
big man so you got three more years left
at college right I'm out for okay hey
meow okay I wait - keep in touch with me
okay I leave my email address because I
want to finance those next four years
the college personally and help you okay
do it for you and keep that dream alive
one day of owning your bakery and then
when your bakery is open all I want back
is a loaf of bread okay it's pretty
unbelievable that he is gonna be able to
finance my four years of school well
done good job they can get the watch
welcome yeah I'm waiting to finish
school and pay em off for their big loaf
of bread you have an amazing pair of
hands and a lovely smile don't stop
okay and God help you if you fail that
College thank you you won't though I
know you won't
well good thank you okay when I go to
school I'm gonna push myself two hundred
times harder I'm gonna sugar in what I
can do and how fast I can do it
goodnight thank you
thank you take care thank you well done
thank you good job awesome job hey you
deserve it definitely